este lunes la corte suprema de eeuu
aceptó escuchar un caso que podría
restringir los derechos reproductivos la
corte estudiará una ley de misisipí que
prohíbe el aborto en la mayoría de casos
tras las 15 semanas de embarazo una ley
estatal que va en contra de la
regulación establecida por el caso roe
contra wade con el que la corte suprema-
sentó jurisprudencia en 1973 para
despenalizar el aborto antes de las 24
semanas por eso dos cortes de menor
jerarquía ya consideraron la ley de
misisipí como inconstitucional en un
comunicado la presidenta del centro por
los derechos reproductivos dijo
suenan las alarmas de amenaza a los
derechos reproductivos la corte suprema-
acaba de aceptar estudiar una
prohibición del aborto que
indudablemente viola casi 50 años de
precedente de la corte suprema y que
podría sentar jurisprudencia para
revocar el marco establecido por el caso
roe contra wade
este será el primer caso relacionado con
el aborto juzgado por la magistrada amy
cón y barrett la católica ultra
conservadora designada por el
expresidente trump en 2020 tras la
muerte de la jueza liberal ruth báder
ginsburg con el cambio el tribunal dio
un giro a la derecha con una mayoría de
seis a tres para los magistrados de
corte conservador si la corte suprema
ratifica la ley de misisipí acabaría con
décadas de derechos reproductivos
reconocidos y abriría la puerta a que
otros estados gobernados por los
republicanos adoptarán legislaciones
parecidas sin embargo la secretaria de
prensa de la casa blanca reafirmó el
compromiso de la administración baiden
con el derecho al aborto
en los últimos cuatro años derechos
básicos como el derecho a la salud el
derecho a elegir han sido
fulminantemente atacados incluyendo
leyes estatales draconianas pero el
presidente y la vicepresidenta están
comprometidos con el acceso a la salud
de todos los estadounidenses incluyendo
el derecho a la salud reproductiva el
presidente está comprometido con brindar
el marco road la corte suprema-
estudiará el caso de misisipí en octubre
y deberá dictaminar la sentencia en 2022